hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well after providing a
definition of art in his short work what
is art
Leo Tolstoy in chapter 5 is going to
help us to understand the scope of what
he thinks art consists in what what
activities what products can be called
art in the full sense of the term and so
in order to understand that we do have
to think a little bit about his
definition or characterization because
that will help us to to understand why
the things he's saying no no this is art
actually would fit into that so he he
gives a couple different closely related
definitions one of the ones that that he
uses in Chapter five runs like this
human activity which consists in one
person's conveying to others by certain
external signs the feelings he or she or
they has experienced and in others being
infected by those feelings and also
experiencing those feelings so there's
really a number of different components
here there's the artifact shoe ality of
it there's some sort of external signs
those don't necessarily have to be
within a you know permanent medium
it could be something like singing right
which which unless you record it
disappears as soon as you're done with
it it's a human activity he also thinks
that there has to be some sort of
intentionality or consciousness there as
well and the key thing here he talks
about art as being a means of communion
between different people who may be
quite distant in space-time or culture
so the communion is about feelings it's
coming the feelings are ones that the
artist the producer has experienced or
at least has imagined and then they
manage to convey them to others through
these external signs to such a degree
that the others become as he says
infected alright that means they take on
those emotions and they experience the
feelings as well so you know think about
what it's like to get angry and then
what it's like to notice yourself being
angry you know we could think about a
case in point the you know famous
painting of Napoleon's soldiers
massacring Spanish civilians you know
you look at that and you're like oh this
is terrible right that's that's a
emotional feeling response there could
be all sorts of them it could be bliss
happiness it could be pleasure which is
one of the things that Tolstoy says art
focuses on too much the pleasure is you
know within the realm of the feelings
right and there's a lot of different
kinds of pleasure could be pride it
could be exultation it could be humility
it could be a sense of remorse it could
be sadness all sorts of possibilities
loneliness is another example as well so
that's the definition of art and if we
understand art in that way he tells us
then we're going to see that
there's there's quite a lot of things
going on because there's so many
different possibilities of these
feelings there's this passage where he
says feelings the most diverse very
strong and very weak significant and
worthless bad and good if only they
infect the reader the spectator the
listener constitute the subject of art
and then he gives a whole bunch of
examples of that as well and he says
that that one case of this the simplest
case a boy who was once experienced fear
let us say on encountering a wolf tells
us about this encounter and to call up
in mind call up and others the feeling
his experience describes himself his
State of Mind before the encounter the
surroundings the forest his carelessness
then the look of the wolf its movements
the distance between the wolf and
himself and so on what he's doing there
is constructing a narrative right that's
an art form telling stories
we almost storytellers who you know
frustrate us because the stories they
tell
seem to be pointless they don't have a
beginning middle and end we don't know
what the story is actually about if
they're a good storyteller we might go
along for the ride
but you know storytelling is an art form
so what happens here he says all this if
he tells if as he tells the story the
boy who lives the feeling he experienced
infects his listeners makes them relive
all the narrator lived through this is
art and then he says something really
interesting even if the boy had not seen
a wolf but had often been afraid of
seeing one and wishing to call up and
others the feeling he experienced
invented the encounter with the wolf so
it's the boy who cried wolf right
this too is art and so he says in say in
the same way it's art if a man having
experienced in reality or an imagination
the horror of suffering or the delight
of pleasure expresses these feelings on
canvas or in marble in such a way that
others are infected by them and he gives
the whole list of different emotions
there so this means that art covers a
wide range and whole story tells us
we're used to thinking of art in a
narrow sense but there's art in a broad
sense and art in a narrow sense so he
says the activity of art is a very
important activity as important as the
activity of speech and as widely spread
so that means that art is is everywhere
quite literally at least it's as
widespread as speech which includes
writings as well so what is art in the
narrow sense this is what we you know
offer classes in and and you know have
curricula about and and blogs and videos
and all of that sort of stuff he says in
the narrow sense of the term we call art
only certain of its manifestations so we
call some of the things that are in the
broad sense art art and that's the
narrow sense of it so he also says we
single these things out and give them
special significance for whatever reason
what are some examples he says we're
accustomed to regard as art only what we
read here see in theaters concerts and
exhibitions buildings statues poems
novels now of course we can expand this
in our own time right we could say well
we now recognize textiles as art we go
to the museum we went to the museum it's
there you go it's still art in the
narrow sense it's what the people who
are the intelligentsia the elite have
chosen to call art what the textbook
producers call art it can expand and
take in other things it can be more
democratic or more you know inclusive or
more representative in whatever terms
you like right but it's still this this
cordoned off domain that doesn't include
as much as would fit under this
definition so
what else fits under there here's some
examples that Tolstoy himself gives he
says the whole of human life is filled
with works of art of various kinds
lullabies singing to a child jokes
that's an interesting one joking around
creates works of art according to
Tolstoy mimicry
imitating another person imitating an
animal imitating something else home
decoration now this is something that I
think many of us would recognize in our
own time as involving art finesse right
we often say well there's arts and then
there's crafts and Tolstoy would say
it's a continuum they're all part of it
so home furnishing home decoration which
by the way Aristotle talks about in
terms of the virtues in Nicomachean
ethics book for clothing utensils and
then he says church services and solemn
processions all this is the activity of
art we might think as well about so many
things that we we have on the internet
right people creating response videos on
YouTube now a lot of them are pretty
cheesy and pretty schlocky and very well
staged and all of that but that could be
considered a kind of art if it produces
a similar response on our part
especially if we've seen the video
before it could be the object of disgust
like you know when the things about
people sharing cups were a big thing on
the internet you know you see something
oh the gross right and then you're like
oh yeah this is kind of gross or it
could be you know watching other things
that they're participating in scary
things oh they respond and now you're
scared too they could also be fanfiction
cosplay could be part of that I mean we
already talked about clothing but think
about what's going on when people engage
in cast
play are they just doing something
that's only for themselves sometimes
they could be but a lot of times they
want other people to see it
and participate in it in a certain way
sometimes they get participation in ways
that they don't like particularly if
they're female and the costumes are
whether the customers don't even have to
be all that scanty exactly we have cast
players in the Wisconsin Center just a
block from where we shoot and you know
you can walk around and see the skeevy
guys looking at the cosplayer not
exactly what Tolstoy has in mind there
because there's not a communion rather
the the cosplaying should be something
like enjoyment right celebration of
fandom and so there's a huge an
incredibly huge expanse of things that
could be considered art Tolstoy does not
talk here about you know say cuisine or
home brewing but perhaps that could be
fitted in there as well or children's
games that they play stylized types of
things so art in the in the Tolstoy in
sense could pervade our entire life he
does think that it is tragic that
because of the way the world is
organized many people don't get to
participate in those forms of art and
have other more narrow conceptions of
art foisted upon them that they can't
really relate to and can't have a
communion in but potentially art is
everywhere and Tolstoy notes later on in
Chapter eight that art can really come
from anywhere it doesn't just come from
the elites that's one of the interesting
things about this this conception of art
anybody could be a producer
anybody can be a participator anybody
can be a consumer anybody can be a
reproducer and you could say remix some
of these things as well so art has a
pretty wide scope when understood in its
broad sense according to Leo Tolstoy
you